hello folks welcome to rational
science I hope my video is coming out
okay and I hope my sound is coming out
okay I would appreciate someone
confirming there
please so let me know if I'm coming out
okay I've got some new equip
uh I also had as you know I've been
blocked by YouTube for two
weeks thank you thank appreciate it uh
I've got some new equipment I got a
different camera so maybe I'm showing up
a little better than in the past I had
that blurry camera which was new by the
way I don't understand why it never
worked anyways the um uh YouTube blocked
me for two weeks I couldn't get in there
I couldn't do anything and uh that was
because I left the country I left
Germany and um uh apparently even though
I took my computer with me the YouTube
did not recognize the IP address and
blocked me and I had I did not have my
phone my son took my phone to the states
so big mess anyways I think I'm back to
where I should be okay uh we'll find out
today anyway is we have a great day
today and one of the things I want to do
also is uh thank take the opportunity as
you can see I've changed my setup here
uh instead of my you know dough
roller uh I've got a sword now so uh
those people who uh make mistakes you
know that need to be treated with the
respect that they re deserve uh I'm
going to stab them okay um anyways I
want to thank the uh patreon supporters
uh who have been following the uh
channel for so long Okay and like I said
you know the day that nobody supports
the program anymore well we'll shut it
down that's all we can do okay what are
we going to do today we're going to do
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what the channel is about for those
people who are new okay some of you may
have forgotten after two three weeks
right uh I'm going to talk a little bit
about Extinction okay we had a couple
papers come out this week or well in
these last two
weeks about the um
dinosaurs how they died so I'm going to
discuss that a little bit and uh in our
Extinction segment which we always have
and uh then I'm going to get to the
subject matter today which is how the
Sun
works and at the end I'll answer maybe a
couple questions that people have made
since last time okay so let's get on
with it what is this Channel about let's
find out this is what is the channel
about okay well uh the first thing is we
challenge math the mathematical method
which is people confus and think it's
the uh scientific method okay this uh
mathematical method has nothing at all
to do with science and that's what
everybody learns in high school and uh
in college and so here's the
mathematical method in shell okay it's
uh we observe that's what they say you
have to gawk that's the first step
gawking uh then you go to explain
tentatively they call that a hypothesis
okay uh they make some kind of
prediction they are all astrologers okay
they say predictions are part of the
mathematical method okay mathematical
method uh they do some kind of
experiment we have no idea why they do
experiments okay uh in fact uh
experiments are a branch of religion
okay we don't do experiments in science
and people say Bill you're crazy what do
you mean we don't do experiments in
science yeah we don't do experiments
because experiments the only purpose of
experiments other than to convince
yourself of something is to persuade
others so we do not do experiments in
science persuading has to do with
convincing the jury you know and that's
got to do with religion not with science
okay so we do not do experiments we
don't describe and that's what
mathematicians do every equation ever
invented is only a description it does
not explain anything and they call those
descriptions those mathematical
descriptions use equation they call them
theories and no in science a theory is
an explanation not a description and it
takes 10 years for a mathematician to
understand the difference um then they
invent some kind of Technology some kind
of Gadget and they call call that a
confirmation of the theory uh they
convince other mathematicians right
their colleagues they call that proof
truth fact maybe knowledge you know any
of those um the colleagues they try to
verify the measurement the equation all
that kind of stuff and they call that
falsification okay it comes from an
Austrian who did falsify a lot of
falsification I guess uh then they win a
prize they grant their prize by their
colleagues it could be a nobble prize a
Templeton prize a wolf prize whatever
and um once you win a prize now you have
uh certified knowledge now you can
trounce anybody on Earth because you've
got you know this degree this higher
degree which is not only a PhD but now
you've been recognized worldwide as a an
authority on something and at that point
you can walk to the celebrity circuit
okay that's more or less uh in a
nutshell uh what the mathematicians do
uh how do we do it in science well we do
it a little differently this is how we
do it in science first we Define the
word science that's what we do and they
never defined the word
science uh you'll find uh definitions
such as the study of etc etc now in
science we don't study you know even a
kindergartener studies does that mean
he's a
scientist you know so uh study is is the
wrong word to use to define uh science
that's the first one but then um you
know uh we they never Define uh science
in a way that we can use it consistently
so here we Define science as rational
explanations okay if you don't have a
rational explanation you are not doing
science and that eliminates quantum
mechanics general relativity strength
Theory special relativity and all
dissidence out there such as you know
the electric Universe uh flat earthers
and other similar to those okay no you
have to have rational explanation what
is a rational explanation or better yet
what is an irrational explanation
irrational explanation is the movement
of Concepts when people start moving
love around and they say look I moved
love or I moved intelligence I moved
conscience you know that's that's when
we have a problem and the mathematicians
you know they transfer energy you know
energy is a concept a mathematical
concept un find one by the way but um uh
you know you can't move a concept or
they move a mass or they uh wave the
wave or they uh warp or bend time you
know so they're doing all these
explanations and they do them all with
Concepts and that's irrational uh we
don't do philosophy here uh very lightly
if anything ever uh but we do physics
and physics re begins with objects you
have to have an object in order to do
physics if God Almighty you know out
there in in heaven I guess uh if he
raises all matter from the
universe what's happening you know
what's going on what's moving you know
what can you explain you know nothing's
happening so you need objects that's the
first thing you need in in physics and
no one in the last 10,000 years not a
single book textbook of physics Begins
by defining what an object is so that's
when we start with a
problem uh but uh once you have that you
have to explain causes and mechanisms
that's what physics is above here again
we do physics here and here you have the
scientific method uh you have a
hypothesis which is not a tentative
Theory as the mathematicians uh think no
it's the set of assumptions okay you
make a set of assumptions essentially
what we call um uh the initial frames of
the film of your film of the theory
you're going to explain so you show the
first frame and say look this is my
starting point okay and there you have
to point at the objects that are going
to be doing that are going to be the
actors that are going to be doing the
emotions right your theory uh you have
to have the definitions they have to be
ground in stone it's what most people
out there call uh semantics uh word
salad word Wizardry that kind of thing
we call them definitions and you must
have definitions what what we call the
foundations of physics you need to have
a certain set of words without which you
cannot give a physical
interpretation and then obviously you
know you have the initial scene uh first
frame of the film and we call those the
statement of the facts then once you
establish that you can move on to give
your explanation you know uh show your
film uh in other words uh tell us the
mechanisms and the causes that's more or
less how it works in science and that's
what we do here and nobody else does
that uh as far as we know anywhere on
the internet anywhere on the
planet okay so yeah uh what we do here
is science physics and we start with
objects and definitions a lot of people
don't like that because they say oh Bill
you're doing semantics you're you're
doing word salad they don't like it
because it destroys their religion
that's why you know you got to have
sound definitions otherwise you can't
get started we need to know what you
mean by your words in other words if
you're going to tell us your theory okay
that's the point okay
um uh let's move on here give me a
second here okay what happened this week
well we had uh some Noble Prize winners
you know we had these people no's prize
goes to Trio Who lit up Secrets uh of
the atom this is incredible that they
would uh find secrets of the atom when
they don't know what an atom looks like
you know to begin with with but uh what
did these people do well there was a
little article that came out in Ohio
because one of these Fells is from Ohio
they were so proud of him that they put
it on the news they said the real
Swedish Academy of Sciences
Sciences recognizes the scholars for
what for experimental methods that
generate at a second attab boy okay uh
pulses of light for the study for the
study of electron Dynamics in matter
well that's technology that's got
nothing to do with science okay so it
says the Swedish Academy of Sciences and
they talk about technology the Nobel
Prize committee said uh that these Fells
one why have given Humanity new tools
for exploring the world of electrons
inside atoms and molecules ahuh and have
demonstrated a way to create extremely
short pulses of light that can be used
to measure the rapid processes in which
electrons move or change energy energy
what the hell is energy and anyways all
that's technology and there you see the
Nobel Prize is the Pinnacle of
scientific achievement no uh it's got
nothing to do with science it's got to
do with technology so don't tell me
you're doing science okay so yeah we
have a problem with this and as you can
see they they uh give all these fellows
these uh Nobel prizes so they have so
they can troun you later on they say
look I've got certified knowledge what
do you have you know that kind of thing
okay um what have all these researchers
always proposed and this shows you the
bottom line how they're different from
us what we do here in this channel okay
all these people have always since the
days of the Greeks okay all the way to
today both dissidents and uh
mathematicians you know the the
mainstream The Establishment they have
always done the same thing they've
always proposed particles particles
particles and most part and more
particles uh they proposed discrete
particles in other words their universe
is a
Sandbox somehow it's a vibrating sandbox
you know where all the particles are
moving around there in space some equate
the particles with space say that space
is made of particles others say that
space
contains the particles as if space were
a container of some kind you know that
has some surface some Edge to it and the
particles are contain within that
container okay and this is what it looks
like okay uh you have 100% researchers
have always proposed particles okay uh
what do the dissident call it they call
it ether they've always called it The
Ether a lot of them know that don't know
that uh what they've been proposing all
these years
are uh bunch of particles that that's
what the ether is and you'll have all
these uh people who call themselves
ethers or who propose The Ether and they
say no no bill you got it wrong wrong
that's not what the ether is and again
all I can tell them don't tell me what
it ain't tell me what it is okay so
don't tell me I'm wrong tell me what's
right okay and this they never come back
they never never have been able to tell
me what the ether is never not one H so
uh if it's a physical object if ether is
a thing I want a drawing I want a
picture I want them to point to a
picture on the internet nothing less
will do okay and don't don't explain it
to me don't describe it to me I want a
picture I want you to point to it okay
that's what that's a then it's an object
you know I I don't say look let me
describe for you a dog or let me explain
to you what a dog is no no no point to a
dog then I'll know what a dog is I know
what the word dog refers to that's how
it works and if you're going to say the
ether is a physical object and you're
going to use it as a physical object
you're going to vibrate it you're going
to do something with it you're going to
make it flow like a river or whatever
point to it before you move anything I
need it static I need a snapshot of it
not not a movie Point okay and uh
general relativity has the same problem
they never got rid of The Ether
SpaceTime is the ether as uh Stephen
Hawkings said
famous uh so-called physicist
mathematical physics mathem magician he
said um what is UHA SpaceTime SpaceTime
is a series of events what's an event
it's a point in SpaceTime so it's kind
of like a circular argument you know
what is spacetime SpaceTime is all the
events that comprise SpaceTime what is
an event it's it's got a set of what
they call coordinates which are really
number lines not coordinates okay and
these number lines point to um a uh
location where an event happened if you
can uh reconcile event with a static
location okay so we have a problem there
too so there are too many problems with
SpaceTime as a proposal to explain for
example what they're going to explain
which is gravity okay warping of
SpaceTime quantum mechanics even worse
you know they talk about particles being
at two places at once Etc but
more in the context that I'm talking
right now uh what they say is that space
is made out of all these virtual
particles and these particle in other
words space is made of it and what
happens one of these virtual particles
comes into the real world so fast that
they can't measure it or detect it but
they said it had to come in because it
affected you know whatever we were doing
so we call it a virtual particle it just
comes in for a split second goes back to
space and the question uh you should ask
is when that particle so-called particle
comes into the real world does it leave
a hole in space
behind so uh and and then after you know
two hours of them giving you their
presentation they say oh by the way
particles ain't particles
particles are
numbers they only have values that's
that's all they deal with so you find
out in the end that the so-called
particle is not the core pusle that for
example Newton was dealing with okay so
all this stuff has to be put in the
proper context I hope I'm still
on okay let me know
otherwise okay so what have they ended
up with after all these centuries okay
especially since the days of Newton last
400 years since the so-called Scientific
Revolution well they ended up with this
they ended up with um irrational
explanations okay they do everything
with particles okay and the rational
explanations is because they move
Concepts around they transfer energy
they move the mass they vibrate the
field
Etc uh black hole what is a black hole
well black hole is allegedly a sun a
star right that compressed all the way
to a point
what is a point point is the center of
nothing because there's nothing there uh
matter according to the great you know
wizards of mathematics uh they say all
matter has been crushed out of existence
of that star all of it there's not a
single atom
left what is mass mass is the quantity
of matter there's no quantity of matter
there's no matter at all so we have no
Mass but they say we have infinite Mass
and with this infinite mathematical
concept called Mass they moved Stars
around they say look uh that stars
orbiting a center and in that Center we
have a big Mass called a black hole so
this is what they ended up with these
are the explanations that we have today
the other one is you know Big Bang uh
the universe Had An Origin yeah who was
it God who moved his what his magic wand
right moved his magic wand and created m
I mean I'll even concede God no problem
I have no problem conceding God I'll
concede God just tell me how God went
from nothing to something what was the
mechanism how did he do it in his
Workshop that's what I want I want to
know the mechanism of how you construct
something from nothing in frame number
one you have nothing frame number two
immediately the next frame I don't care
how many frames your movie has the next
frame you have something how did God do
it okay so of course what the
mathematician they always stop at frame
number two they never go to frame number
one they say look we don't know there
was a singularity there already and so
where did the singularity come from well
we don't know we that's unscientific
it's an unscientific question because we
have no way of testing the
hypothesis that's the answer you get so
yeah all these people move Concepts
around that's why it's all absolute
poock nonsense what we have from the
mathematical establishment but they are
the scientists of the they're recognized
as a scientist no one else is and so go
fight that okay okay so um what is
different between uh what these people
do and what we do here we have a little
bit a different way of looking at the
universe okay and here it is this is in
a nutshell okay this is the bottom line
okay uh mathematical physics and all
dissidents they have particles they call
it the ether they call it the false
vacuum they have all these names for
that they call it energy uh whatever
they say space is filled with all these
particles sometimes space is the
particle sometimes it ain't okay what do
we have we have a single thread in all
of space that's all we have okay we call
it the Rope hypothesis not because it's
a rope but the Rope comes in later uh
but there's a single thread if we were
to untangle every atom in the universe
uh this is what we would find we would
find a single thread uh floating in
space okay that's that's our starting
point
so what happens with this thread okay to
show you how we're different than all
the rest well this is this is uh how we
envision it the single closed loop
thread um you know uh twined around
itself and created all the atoms
connected by these ropes DNA like ropes
um that bind any two atoms in the
universe every atom in the universe is
physically connected because we are all
part of the single close Loop thread
this is our universe okay that's our
starting point and I'm not going to go
into more detail on that because I've
done that in the past I'm just going to
show very quickly um how the Rope is
connected which is our standard model
that's why we call it the Rope
hypothesis okay this is the construction
okay we have uh the magnetic thread and
the electric thread we just Ed to be
with convention right that's why we use
the word electric and magnetic and
nothing else both thre are exactly the
same they come from the same single
thread in the universe there you have
our atom okay so our atom is not a
little bead that rolls around the
nucleus instead it's a couple threads
one thread goes through the center of
the atom the other one CLS around and
encapsulates the star that is contained
in there and this is a 2d version there
you see the 3D version on the lower left
okay it's a essentially a membrane that
encapsulates a star that's what an atom
really looks like according to us and
the red line there curved red line
that's the electron shell you can see
the ropes stop at the electron shell and
they the two threads Fork out one goes
to the center of the through the center
of the atom the other one coils around
and encapsulates the proton star okay so
this is our model okay and with this we
can explain um not only light which is
the torsion of the Rope but we can
explain also um
how the atom is built in other words why
it does its Quantum jump okay it's not
the little bead jumping back and forth
but the a membrane which expands and
contracts okay so we have a totally
different model and we think and our
model by the way is really the model
that's used by chemistry okay the
chemists you know they have these
balloons and that's what we say the atom
is in other in on the other hand the
mathematicians they say it's a little be
that goes back and forth and the
question is why what what triggers what
compels the little bee to go towards the
nucleus and to go out or or prevent it
from flying out spontaneously that's one
issue the other one is when the electron
goes close to the proton which is
positive the electron is negative why
doesn't it get stuck to the proton I
mean you know positive I thought
attracted negative and here they make it
come close to it but then they have it
come back out so they cheat that's what
they do uh they don't have a model and
uh of course they say well we don't know
what an atom looks like hydrogen atom
right uh in fact none of the atom they
have never seen an atom whenever they
took a picture uh you know like uh
through the sem scanning electron
microscope or the atomic Force
microscope right which have abilities to
to see very well and I know because I
was certified on the SS um uh you can
uh a lot of stuff there that you cannot
see in normal you know normal everyday
life and but what what do you see you
see balls whenever you look at a bunch
of Adams they say look we've taken a
picture of Adams yeah what have they
taken a picture of a bunch of balls you
do not see little beads going around
painting you know uh orbitals or energy
levels or whatever nonsense they call it
in quantum mechanics no what you see is
balls you see membranes and that's what
the chemists also use okay so we're in
line with the chemist and not the
so-called mathematical physics
physicists okay folks that's what the
channel is about in general terms okay
let's move on to our Extinction segment
okay and what was this about well we um
we start by saying that in this channel
we say that we are the last humans on
Earth we're the last generation of
humans on Earth okay we're going to all
die very soon uh can't tell you how many
months how many years I can only have a
sense of that and people say Bill are
you a prophet uh have you seen the
future had you had a bad dream or you
are you in touch with God or something
like that no no it's got to do with
Theory with explanation that's what we
do here science science is what rational
explanations we have to explain how
extinctions happen and no one in the
last 10,000 years since at least since
the days of George Korea in h France you
know who came up with paleontology not a
single paleontologist on Earth can tell
you how species become extinct they
can't tell you how the dinosaurs became
extinct how the synapsis became extinct
how the uh how plants become extinct
they they have no idea whatsoever and
they've been uh for the last 200 years
they've been twiddling around with the
same theories over and over and over and
they can't hit it because they're
looking for
catastrophes for mass extinction for um
background extinctions they have a
different mechanism man killed everybody
we killed the nandal we killed the
woolies we killed the the dodos we
killed the passenger pit we killed them
all the great AR we killed them all
we're respond we're the murderers and
that's all they have okay so they have
no EXP explanation for background or
mass extinctions so what we do here we
try to set them straight and show them
how Extinction happens okay so there
were a couple of papers uh I think in
the last week here's the first one says
life science North Dakota fossil site
reveals when asteroid killed dinosaurs
ahuh so so they are able to determine
you know when uh the asteroid killed the
dinosaur they know was an asteroid
that's been proven beyond that right so
um okay so they say they went in there
and looked at some spals and they say
look we found them in the mouths or in
the stomachs of some fish that were
there okay that they found the skeletons
over there in in North Dakota uh it
turns out that if you looked at look at
where you know where um these um where
the asteroid hit which was in the
Yucatan you know uh south of the Gulf of
Mexico right and you wonder how those
ferals made it all the way to North
Dakota okay and this is one of the
questions you should keep in mind but
this is what they're saying they've
already proven that the asteroid killed
the dinosaurs now they're looking for I
don't know for some evidence of
different kinds to be able to write
their papers I guess that's all they're
just trying to become famous or
something saying oh we discovered this
or we discovered that so yeah we we
don't pay attention to all the asteroid
okay who say that they've discovered how
uh the dinosaurs died okay and you saw
just now that was Brimstone uh they have
another version uh because remember when
the asteroid hit the water it created
all these tsunamis and you have this you
have all these uh this water world you
know and the water spilled over the land
and just uh overwhelmed everything it
just uh covered the land with water
uh drowned out all the trees all the
dinosaurs and I would assume even the
tiny little mammals that were you know
in the waiting in the wings for the
dinosaurs to die uh so I don't know how
they survived this but yeah they have
all this stuff they they want to make
sure that you understand that they that
uh the asteroid killed everything you
know everywhere on Earth uh nothing
survived and so the question is you know
how come we're here did God create Adam
and Eve all over again or how did that
happen I mean they create the animals
the everything all over again you know
so uh you know you got to have some
questions about these people who claim
that the asteroid uh theory is correct
okay and that you cannot dispute it okay
so here um here we have another version
and uh this is the
um other article that came out says uh
that uh they cannot agree on whether it
was the AST
or volcanism you know the decan traps in
India they spewed lava for millions of
years I guess you know and they swamped
the land with lava and so either the
asteroid killed us or or the decen traps
killed us and uh a lot of people favored
the decen traps because it was a slower
process whereas the other one was
catastrophic it happened you know now
and you know it was that was it okay you
know it's like happened real quick and a
lot of people especially paleontologists
have problems with that because they say
look you know we can see in the record
that the die off was slow towards the
end of the
Cretaceous you know it it wasn't like
today you know it was like several
million years you had species
disappearing gradually and then suddenly
you know they were you know suddenly
they they were gone and so they say no
no it was the volcanoes you know they
spewed lava slowly and they changed the
atmosphere and all that stuff and
eventually killed all the animals so you
have these two versions these are the
two primary versions by the way okay so
this is what the fight is about and
there you see it uh uh they they have
this tug of war between them between the
uh asteroids okay the impactors and the
Vulcan
Vulcans okay so this is the fight okay
and um just in case we had uh as always
in mathematics you have proof
fortunately we have what would we do
without proof without evidence right and
here we have a a paper that was written
in 2010 41 people signed it all these
scientists
scientis and what do they do they
confirm that the chicksa love impact uh
triggered the mass extinction period
we're done we proved it no more
discussion okay so the this is the
official version now and some some
people don't like it especially the
vulcanus you know the people who uh I
guess they they uh watch Star Trek or
something I don't know and here they are
here's um the two primary exponents of
um of each one of the theories one was
the Alvarez Father and Son team Louie
and uh Walter Alvarez uh they were
involved in discovering the idium that
you know the
asteroid spread throughout the planet
and that's on the one hand and on the
other you have uh Dewey McLean and he
was a fellow who said who wrote a paper
in fact two years earlier before the
Alvarez uh where he
discussed um that the decen traps
probably created the uh demise of the
dinosaurs so here you have this is the
about between uh Alvarez and
McLean dwey on the left and uh and Louie
on the right so we have Dy against Louie
okay so and what happened was since
Alvarez um he had a Nobel Prize in
physics in
physics uh in
mathematics uh you know it's important
to know that that little bit of detail
okay Alvarez was in the great artist the
airplane that followed the airplane that
threw the bomb over I think uh over
Hiroshima okay and using that plane uh
to try to find out you know to measure
what the explosion you know how many
people killed all that kind of good
stuff and he was a guy who worked for
the military he worked in um in Alamos
uh in in the what is it the um where
they developed the
bomb and he was into Radars and because
of his radar work you the military and
other people uh friends you know they
got him a Nobel Prize because of all
that okay again again technology nothing
to do with science okay especially he's
a Quantum mechanic okay so he could have
been a scientist but it turns out that
once he had that Nobel Prize now he's
got a little bit of authority and he
went there and helped his son who was a
geologist okay and uh so he put his
weight behind the paper in 1980 and he
got it published and since then it's
become the law you know the way the
dinosaurs died was because of that
asteroid strike and nobody can take it
back now okay so that's it okay take it
or leave it or take it or take it you
know that's it okay so we have this uh
this bout between mle and they went to
uh mle went to a conference together
with Alvarez and Alvarez troun him troun
him not because he he was right or
because of anything just because he had
more Authority and he was able to
convince all the mathematicians that he
was right and that Dy was wrong so Louie
won against dwey okay and in fact he
embarrassed him he uh he treated them
quite
roughly okay so uh poor old Dewey he he
found out the hard way how science
really works you know political
science okay so here we have uh the
Alvarez hypothesis okay let's go with
him because I want to cover this because
really whether you use the volcanism you
deck and traps or you use uh
asteroid the the idea is that U you know
the changes were so drastic one was fast
the other one was slow but the the
changes affected our atmosphere the air
we breathe the waters everything and so
you would think it kills all animals or
you know and and it it doesn't answer
the primary question that Extinction
must answer always okay if you did not
not answer this issue you do not know
anything about Extinction and it's just
that simple and the issue is
selectivity okay if you cannot explain
selectivity if your theory does not
explain
selectivity you do not have a theory
okay and uh and this is the problem the
problem is that you know
volcanoes and uh especially asteroids
they're not intelligent enough to be
able to discern between especially you
know in a chronological way between the
old species and the new species and what
always always
dies in a mass extinction also in a
background extinction by the way uh are
the old
species so that's a Common Thread you
can put my my hand in the fire for that
okay so here it is this is the Alvarez
hypothesis and this is uh his uh paper
that he published in 1980 this is his
famous paper okay I just want to show
you he talked about extraterrestrial
impact idium right he says idium can
only come in in such quantities from an
asteroid strike and so he goes in and he
says a hypothesis suggested which what
accounts for the extinctions and the
idian observations impact of a large
Earth Crossing asteroid would inject
about 60 times the object's Mass into
the atmosphere's pulverized Rock so he
goes on in his paper talking about
uh math because that's all he knows how
to talk about okay so he goes in there
does a lot of numbers for us how much it
weighed how big it was you know uh what
how fast it was traveling all that kind
of nonsense and with that he says I've
explain extinction of the dinosaur right
uh no I'm sorry Louie I I don't think
you did okay all you did was give me a
bunch of numbers worthless numbers that
uh do not tell me the mechanism of how
the dinosaur has disappeared and here
let me show you the outline of his paper
just so you see where I'm coming from on
all this um those are the titles uh or
you could say the headlines of each one
of the groups U you know of of of his
whole paper right and they're all
numbers they're all he he just goes into
with evidence and numbers and equations
that's all he does right and the only
one that's of interest to science is the
one that says biological effects he's
got only five
paragraphs under biological effects
probably one of the shortest part of his
paper okay and I just put the first two
of them there uh not the other three
because they're even less relevant than
these two but it says a temporary
absence of sunlight would effectively
shut off photosynthesis and thus attack
food chains at their
Origins okay yeah okay I don't know
about that says terrestrial vertebrates
did survive they may have been able to
do this by feeding insects and decaying
vegetation in other words the trus okay
okay so this is uh this is all he says
essentially uh about the mechanisms but
I like his last statement his last
paragraph better and here is this one's
even better uh so if you read this paper
you'll see this and it says we will not
go further into this matter meaning of
explaining the mechanisms of how the
dinosaurs disappeared right but we refer
the reader to the proceedings of the
1976 out ofwa meeting on the CT
Extinction this volume reproduces an
extensive discussion among the
participants of what would happen if the
sunlight were temporarily turned off
those involved in the discussion seem to
agree that many aspects of the
extinction pattern could be explained by
this mechanism although a number of
puzzles remained so he says if you want
to know the mechanism you got to go to
AWA 1976 you know maybe um uh what is it
time travel go back there and find out
what it was all about he doesn't say
anything in his paper about the
mechanism of how the dinosaur died how
that asterid actually created the death
of the animals he just said look it
turned out the sunlight you know there
was no more sun and all animals die but
the mammals remain because they ate the
DRS that's all he says and you know it
turns out that he wasn't the first you
know to come up with a lot of these
theories because you know you had the
Lin Fels what was it 1956 he wrote a
paper already said hey extraterrestrial
impact you know so so uh others copied
it from the lenells but it turns out the
lenells wasn't the first one either if
you go back and time you find out that
all the way to the 18th century 18th
century you had uh the French right uh
laas was one um I can't remember the
other guy but I forget his name here
I'll give it to you in a second second
but the m p I think was the other one it
turns out that these two guys already
talked about impacts they already
thought about it so the impact theory
has been around for 200 over 200 years
so what did Alvarez discover what did he
invent well it turns out all he
presented was evidence numbers that's
what the mathematicians want to hear and
that's what they got and that's why he
you know alare became a king in
paleontology because that's what the
mathematicians call science you know the
numbers not the
mechanism and we don't care about your
stupid equations about your measurements
we want to know what the mechanism was
that killed the dinosaurs how did the
asteroid you know distinguish between
the old species and the new species the
dinosaurs were the old species the new
species were the mammals these were big
these guys are small right uh how did
the plants disappear okay how did the
conifers disappear why were they taken
over uh by the angiosperms you got to
explain all that you can't say an
asteroid did that makes no sense
whatsoever and so yeah that's what we
have okay on the other side we have
Dewey we had Louie okay now now we go
with Dy dwey really wrote a paper two
years before um Alvarez uh 1978 and this
is a paper from
1985 7 years later five years after he
was beaten up right and this is what uh
dwey says he says look CO2 accumulation
in the atmosphere that's one of the
things that he proposes right this in
turn triggers chemical changes in the
mixed layer uh climatic warming I heard
about that you know climate change right
perturbation of the carbon cycle DEC
contract volcanism elevated rate of
mantle CO2 release okay and carbon
dioxide side right tertiary dropping
oxygen 18 so so what is he saying he's
saying look oh then the last one there
the pH change you know it changed the
waters the the the you know the taste of
the waters I guess right so they have
all these or the acidity right so the
the issue here is that these people um
are proposing that uh climate change
that the gases changed in the air or the
waters changed they became more acidic
or or whatever or maybe a combination of
all of them
and again uh you cannot explain with
that selectivity which is the only thing
they have to explain okay if the lava
covered the land it killed everything so
first they have to say explain why
animals uh on the other side of the
planet how did they die you know how was
the cell activity there done by you know
these uh lava that came from over here
and they say okay it was the change the
atmosphere change the climate Okay so
why did some survive why did some other
did not you know and and so you have to
explain that SEL activity and more so I
mean these are very intelligent
volcanoes because you know in every
instance for especially in the peran
which is more or less they have the same
uh mechanism you know
volcanism um they um what they never are
able to explain and in every case you
have the same situation the old species
died they never realized this and a new
species the one that came much later
those are the ones that survived so all
these catastrophes or whatever you want
to call them um they suffer of the same
problem that they have all these
mechanism asteroids uh um what is it um
Vol volcanoes Etc or plumes coming out
of the ground and all these other
mechanisms that they invent and all of
them not a single one can tell you
selectivity can explain Cel activity
especially chronological SEL activity
why the old species that were about to
die anyways why they died and why the
new species which were supposed to
continue rolling why they continued to
thrive okay so this is the issue okay
okay and uh the Baton for the follow
Dewey is carried out today by this lady
uh her name is um Gera Keller and that's
her uh on the right there she's the one
on the right by the way not far right
okay just in case okay and uh she's the
one that uh continues with the Baton and
uh just like Dy she is ridiculed even to
this day for proposing vulcanism which
if anything um is a little better than
the asteroid Theory but you know both of
them are nonsense there's no way you can
explain the extinction of the dinosaurs
with any of these catastrophic uh AC um
agents okay so this is where the problem
is uh and again let me just uh
analyze uh the asteroid one so that you
can see what the problem is with what
these people are saying okay here's the
asteroid strike okay and the asteroid
comes to Earth hits us and there it is
you know and it hits the Yucatan the
chickalo um what is known as the
chickaloo crater uh allegedly this is
what it looks like okay when it hit
there you see the crater on the left
there you see it the map on the right
okay and uh by the way you know I was in
a conference in uh the Czech Republic
and some Mexicans came over and they
were looking at this because uh they
were part of uh tourism uh for their
country and they said look yeah we're
we're trying to promote the chick Lube
crater so that you know tourists come
over there and we're trying to build it
up so you know they want to create it
into a tourist side and they're going to
take them by boats to see the crater
maybe you know go underwat who knows and
you know I told them you know the crater
has absolutely first of all that's not a
uh a strike an asteroid strike and
that's a long story for me to explain
but uh that's the the first issue but
the second issue it's got nothing to do
with the extinction of the dinosaurs
absolutely not okay um so what kill the
the dinosaur you we we want to know well
for sure it wasn't this because here you
see what the asteroid does to the Earth
according to these people this is the
official version by the way okay here's
the Earth it got hit by this asteroid
and the whole earth is burning
everything died the Earth became a s the
whole surface became like a cinder
that's that's the that's the official
version okay so uh you say well if
everything
died uh why are we around today why are
mammals around how did they survive you
know what did they I mean forget about
eating I mean they weren't burned they
weren't uh drowned by tsunamis and etc
etc etc you know how did they survive
how did the animals underwater you know
the reptiles the big reptiles like mosar
and so on they died they disappeared and
the fish remained uh uh they say snakes
survived Turtles survived some Crocs
survived you know some of these animals
survived and how come how did they kill
only the the reptiles and the reptiles
in the air the birds survived but the
repti the flying reptile like you know
um what is it Kel quad uh he survived I
mean he died but all the birds uh
survived so how does the asteroid do
that I mean this is a quite intelligent
asteroid and so yeah the way um the way
we show that it's nonsense what all
these people are proposing is uh with a
little graph okay this graph I've shown
it in the past I'll show it one more
time so please do not
yawn here it goes okay this is the
Cretaceous terrestrial Revolution it
took four years to build this graph okay
by uh people who went over the records
and what you see there is what happened
in the last uh you could say almost 80
million years of the Cretaceous Period
and what you see is the angiosperms
muscled all the other U types of plants
aside specifically the pads the pads
were the ones who that were ruling the
planet at that point especially um
together with the conifers right uh Psy
are conifers but I mean with other
conifers and uh what happened was this
vegetation disappeared it be not
disappeared completely in in every
instance but uh you can see the forest
and jungles were disappearing and it
were being taken over by the angos
sperms angos sperms not were taken over
the land that's what was happening who
ate angiosperms mammals who ate coners
well they say that um dinosaurs also ate
angiosperms and Ferns and all this stuff
no no way no possible way and I'll tell
you why you know there's no way that I
don't you know I don't need evidence
they say get some evidence Bill no we
don't need evidence for this this is
very simple and here let me show it to
you uh fact I think I have it here okay
there it is uh and that's at the bottom
um for every age you had a certain type
of plant and the animals that um develop
developed with respect to those plants
that was their food source so if you go
to the perian uh you'll find maybe the
glossopteris uh if you go to Triassic
you'll find Dums and these were uh seed
FMS okay so the seed firms what is what
these animals ate and there were no
angiosperms at the time uh the gymnos
sperms were were just being born and so
in those days they had really no for all
practical purposes they had no
gymnosperms and they had no angiosperms
all they had was these seed Ferns and
some nonvascular and early vascular
plants that's all they had okay so every
age has a type of plant and the Animals
especially the hers they have no other
choice but to eat what or develop with
the plants that they have underneath
their feet okay what happen when these
plants disappear guess what the animals
disappear the herbivores disappear and
with them the carnivores and you see the
same pattern in each one of these major
ages you go to jurassic okay and you had
again the the conifers and especially
the uh pads and psyched lies the William
sonans and so on they had all these
plants that they ate and when those
plants disappeared at the end of the
Cretaceous guess what you know the
dinosaurs disappeared because that's
what they ate dinosaurs did not not eat
at least uh maybe there was one animal
out there that ate it I don't know but
uh you know when you develop with a
certain type of plant you don't change
overnight and say well I think I'm going
to eat angos sperms today instead of
conifers it doesn't work that way you
know try feeding um pine trees to a
rabbit see see if he likes it and you
say well a plant is a plant is a plant
isn't it no it ain't you can't feed
ferns to to a mammal okay and uh you
can't feed conifers to a mammal mammals
were born with
angiosperms and the day the angiosperms
go away mammals will go away and there
you see the graphs at the top of the um
pyramids uh in the case of a background
Extinction uh which we Define as The
Disappearance of one species whereas the
max mass extinction is the disappearing
of an entire food chain and as you can
see I've highlighted the word food okay
that's what a mass extinction is it has
to do with food food when food
disappears that uh order or that family
or whatever disappears with it and there
you see what happened you have the
overturning of the ecological pyramid
for a mass extinction and because it
overturns uh that's why the animals die
why does it overturn well you can see it
there on the left uh the green pyramids
they're for the plants that's what
overturns what overturns is the is the
um uh
population pyramid of the plants and
that happens naturally you don't need a
you don't need a catastrophe like an
asteroid or volcano or anything like
that all you need is uh time and over
time the plants lose uh genetic
diversity and at some point uh they
their pyramids overturn and they are
taken over by more Vibrant Plants the
gymnos sperms replaced the seed ferns
they disappeared completely at the end
of the Triassic and then the angiosperm
disa made the gymnosperms essentially
disappear especially the pyats we don't
have pyats today I think they all you
have is genos uh bobas that's the
only ancient plant that survived from
that age all the other the pads the pyad
like they disappeared okay so when those
plants disappeared guess what happened
to the dinosaurs they disappeared what
happens um uh is is that the uh
population pyramid of the plant
overturns when that happens the animals
that depended on that source of food
cannot change overnight rabbits don't
start eating you know pine trees because
they have no you know no angiosperms to
eat it doesn't happen they don't go from
lettuce to pine leaves doesn't happen
Okay um and here's just an example okay
here you have the mosasaurs at the end
of the cretes and they ate
ammonites um which ate uh Plankton and
when the Plankton disappeared especially
the big ones they were replaced by
smaller ones which apparently uh were
not so tasteful for the ammonites the
ammonites no longer ate those uh the the
new um planktons and so they disappeared
in the mo mosar with them so this food
chain this just an example okay
disappeared because of that because one
depended on the other again a mass
extinction has to do with The
Disappearance of a food chain
and that's why we need to Define these
terms we need to Define what a
background Extinction is and you go to
the Wikipedia and what do you find they
say uh you look for background
Extinction it gives you the background
Extinction rate a mathematical concept
nonsense from the mathematical
establishment they tell you how many
species disappeared in the background
they look at numbers we don't care we
want to know why what caused The
Disappearance of a given species at a
different point in time and for that you
have to explain The Disappearance of one
species how did Mother Nature Target a
single species like for example the
Neanderthals kill them and leave
everybody alive that's what you got to
explain okay and that's what these
people cannot explain they've never were
able to explain Extinction whether
background or uh uh mass extinction here
we do we have an explanation and not
only we can explain it we say we go one
step further we say it's a foolproof
mechanism okay there's no way to avoid
it humans are going to die because in a
mass extinction not in a background
Extinction we're going to die with all
the mammals okay because we're going to
take care of them before we die we're
going to kill every animal that we can
find okay but we're going to disappear
why because of an asteroid or because
you know God said so in the Bible or
because you know volcanoes Absolut or or
maybe even a supernova as they say say
no none of those agents have anything to
do with Extinction we're going to die
because our population pyramid uh
population pyramid of our plants are
going to overturn okay why because we
create our own food and the only reason
we do so is because of money so uh all
uh mass extinctions ultimately are
economic uh problem are caused by
economics all animals have economics all
animals manage a single resource which
is food where that food disappears the
animal no longer has anything to manage
and right now we make our own food okay
without food We All Die Here on planet
Earth why do we produce food and
distribute it because of money when the
economy of the world collapses we're all
dead because nobody will produce food or
distribute it to the cities and we have
all these people in the cities millions
of people and they depend on someone
bringing a Golden Spoon and feeding them
so all mass extinctions are related to
food we will die why because food will
run out why because our economic system
will collapse we cannot grow forever
economically especially when the
population doesn't grow anymore okay so
that in a nutshell is the extinction
theory of this
channel okay let's move on to the
subject matter of today and that's the
Sun how does the sun
work well there's two issues we got to
look at as far as the sun is concerned
um the first one is gravity because we
have you know all these planets rolling
around the
Sun why why are we so faithful to our
son why don't we you know take our leave
and go out of the solar system you know
fly around the universe I'd love to you
know with our whole planet you know
going throughout the Universe would you
like that you know but the sun doesn't
let us somehow it's we're bound to the
Sun how by by what mechanism are we
bound to the sun even worse uh the sun
is bound to the center of the Milky Way
in fact in a plane like almost all
galaxies all galaxies are
flat and the question is why the Galaxy
spins there's a star there and it
doesn't leave even the ones on the
outside you know they don't fly away
it's it's like you know uh like the
Quantum atom you know you have this
little electron B drawing around the
nucleus and you ask well what doesn't
fall to the nucleus I mean gravity you
know or positive uh nucleus attracting
negative electron should be attracting
right and then if not uh why doesn't the
electron leave why does it keep going
back and forth you know between energy
levels why don't the electron just fly
away so these are important questions in
fact uh the one Falling Towards the cent
center of the nucleus was the one that
got us started at the beginning of the
20th century that's what they were
investigating why you know because they
had this um other adom that uh what's
his name um I can't remember the guy's
name now but anyways they they had a
different Plum P pudding uh model and
they said well that one doesn't explain
why the electron doesn't fall okay and
so they went in there did some tests and
you got all the way to Neil's bore and
he said look you know I've got to solve
it's a planetary model you have the
electron going
around and no that does that don't work
either okay you have to explain why the
electron doesn't fall to the nucleus or
why it doesn't spontaneously leave the
atom if you cannot explain that you
don't have a model of the atom and
that's what we have today because that's
what the the planetary model is what
they used to explain ionization uh
Quantum jump uh electricity all that's
explained with the with the quantum
model with the this planetary model okay
so that's where we stand okay so here we
have our Milky Way okay here we have
them okay and one of those is our star
and the question is why if that thing is
turning around you know why doesn't it
spit out our sun or any of the Stars
right there at the periphery here you
have a spiral galaxy okay more or less
the same thing you ask the same question
you know uh well if all those stars are
going around why don't they fly away
what's keeping them
uh tied to the center I mean we're
talking about a star star like a sun is
gigantic many times the size of our uh
Earth millions of times and yet it
doesn't you know it just it's it's alone
you know it's it's just one another star
like all the others there and yet they
all orbit a center for no reason
whatsoever why don't they fly
away and you can't say well it's gravity
it's Mass because those are Concepts
again you cannot explain a mechanism
with with Concepts which is what they do
they say it's Mass it's gravity that's
not a mechanism that's a mathematical
concept and what they want to do is
replace physics with mathematics and say
well it's Mass if you have so much mass
then you know the star doesn't fly away
but see that's only a description a
mathematical description that doesn't
give you a physical
mechanism physical mechanism is you know
I tie a rope around a donkey and I
pull and uh and someone asked or I ask
you know uh how did I get the donkey to
come closer to me so very easy you know
you tied a rope and I saw you pull on
the rope that was tied to the neck of
the donkey and I can see and visualize
and I can explain to anyone how the
donkey approached
you how did they how do you do that with
stars you know is uh a star being held
together by some kind of rope towards
the center are the planets here here you
have the planets okay here's our planet
this is the solar system okay you have
all the um uh planets rolling around the
earth uh around the Sun how come they
don't leave how come they don't fly away
and uh you know this this is a different
version here some people say no this is
the way they they turn around okay uh no
problem okay you want it that way
because the sun is rolling around the
Milky Way no problem tell me why they
keep rolling around the Sun you you can
see that they're not flying away it's
like they're tied to the sun it's like
they're feathered to the sun okay and so
here's here's the question for you the
million dollar question you got to think
today about when you look at uh how the
sun does its thing in the solar system
uh is this is this what's
happening is it like uh here we have
okay is it is this what's happening you
know you're you've got um uh maybe
somehow the Earth is Tethered to the sun
the sun is Tethered to the center of the
Milky Way is that what's
happening okay so this is one of the
things you got to keep in mind right uh
maybe we're bound we're tied as we say
with a rope model that we're all tied
together whether we like it or not we're
bound to each other okay uh here's
another version of that just in case uh
similar okay you have the cowboy rolling
the is lasso is this what's happening
okay so these are the things for you to
keep in mind today as we go
along okay so how did uh our solar
system start according to the
establishment okay what started with a
what is called a nebular hypothesis they
say there was a nebula a bunch of gases
and stones and other debris that came
out of an explosion of another star
system a long time ago you know some
kind of supernova said throw all this
garbage into our neighborhood so we have
all these gases right
hydrogen perhaps helium you know and you
have all this debris and all this slowly
condensed and kind of got together and
here you have a picture of it okay uh
well this is just a just
a synthesis you know you see the nebula
there on the upper left and as you go to
the lower right you can see what's
happening the the uh gas cloud condenses
and creates these orbits and in each
orbit you have all these U gases and
debris that eventually condensed into a
star okay this is the official version
and here let me show you the uh how they
visualize it more or less like this okay
especially our Earth one of these uh
little um things gas clouds and debris
turns into our Earth okay
so um this is the official version okay
you have the sun which was uh cond which
is condensed gas essentially right and
some gases remained outside okay and
they turned into these planets such as
the Earth the rocky planets and here's a
version of how they think it happened
okay this is called the iron catastrophe
let me get this one out of
here okay you can see it
there and what it is is essentially they
have um all this
debris hit something there you know they
they accumulate together with gases I
guess and the Earth comes out and we say
this is poppycock this is nonsense this
never happened okay now we make a
distinction between this the sun and the
planets especially the rocky planets you
know uh Mercury Venus all the way to
Mars and the moons of each one of the
planets okay because you got a problem
if as they say there was this ring of
gas and
debris why did we have a planet like the
like Jupiter or Saturn which are gaseous
planets which are stars that weren't big
enough to ignite and they're surrounded
by Rocky PL uh moons that go around them
you know IO Europa ganam they go around
Jupiter and these are rocky planets that
are in the same ring as the gas that
supposedly formed part of the nebula
that made the
sun you know you get explain that how
how did those little uh moons come into
being and yeah we have a different
version here totally different version
it's not ours by the way I don't take
credit for it I just I'm glad I
discovered it because I had this
question to all all the way from high
school
why um our planet is or why all these
rocky planets are perfectly round you
could say almost perfectly right round
they're sperical except for flat
earthers and then uh why are they
differentiated you know as you go to the
Center of the Earth you get to uh uh
heavier elements and as you go out not
only you get through uh um weaker El
elements but you get all the way to
gases I mean we're surrounded by air air
is oxygen maybe there's some hydrogen
and helium floating around it's all
gases that surround our planet same with
uh Mars okay same with Venus not so with
uh Mercury but you know all these have
the same structure they're heavy in the
center lighter on the outside all the
way to gases that's around the
planet um and and what you're what I'm
describing is a star
Earth was a star okay so Earth was a
star a long time ago that condensed and
turned into a planet what is known as a
black um black uh what black dwarf a
black dwarf uh what is the problem well
the problem is that a black dwarf takes
what at least a trillion years to form
and that's a little longer than the Big
Bang which happen only a petty 14 milon
years ago so you can see the problem if
there are black dwarfs which they say
they they can't be any black dwarfs out
there but if the Earth is a black dwarf
you can see the problem that would
create for Big Bang Theory okay it would
knock it out of the sky uh you know
sudden death that's what it would happen
so yeah the the big problem here is that
the um that there are black dwarves and
our planet is one is a black dwarf what
is a black dwarf a star that that uh you
know served its course ran its uh
completely through its course and shrunk
to or compressed to a planet and then it
got rid of most of its gaseous surface
and ours REM stayed with you know
remained with uh some oxygen around it
others like Mercury and uh like U I'm
sorry Mars and Venus they have uh
CO2 carbon dioxide but that's that's the
you know that's a star that's what it is
all these are stars and so anything that
I see round into the solar system any
Moon any satellite you know of Jupiter
Saturn whatever all those were stars
they were
compressed uh that's why they're round
that's why they're
differentiated and uh and so it's got
nothing to do with this nebular
hypothesis that they have out there the
nebular hypothesis I do accept for the
Sun okay but I'm saying that all those
gases condensed and became the sun which
was the last member of the solar system
all the other planets were already in
the Stars right Stars black dwarves they
were already there and when the sun
ignited they were already there waiting
for the sun to ignite that's the way we
look at it here okay and so yeah here uh
we say that the Earth was a star and the
problem there is with a big bang
um they tell you that something existed
in frame number two which is a
singularity so the question is what was
there before the singularity what was in
frame number one of the universal movie
and that's what they never answered they
said that's an unscientific uh question
you know and so yeah if God's going to
turn nothing into something I want to
know what the mechanism is I don't care
if you put God in there if you take him
away I it doesn't matter the question is
tell me how we went from frame one
number one to frame number two that's
all you got to explain and of course
they uh never answer that question
because they
can't and so they just dismiss it as an
unscientific question because they can't
put an equation or measure anything
there so they say it's unscientific
that's the way they handle these
questions okay so that's the gravity
part okay how does gravity work why
don't the planets leave uh the solar
system why doesn't the sun leave the
Galaxy you get answer that question
that's part of the functioning of a star
that you have to answer gravity okay now
let's go to the other part how does uh
the sun a star any Star for that
matter um create light what do you call
it energy whatever that is how does it
produce energy you know heat light how
does it do that and it does it every day
every day it doesn't burn you know you
try it try it at home always this
experiment in the presence of a
relativist right so that you don't get
hurt get a match and light it and see if
it lasts uh a million
years no no that match is only lasts a
second so we got a problem with that
because you know it turns out turns off
very easily uh so apparently that sun is
not just a ball of fire in the sense
like a campfire there's something else
going on there we have to explain that
something else how does that work okay
with the establishment's version well
it's Fusion okay here you have from
Universe today Fusion of four protons
hydrogen molecules it really should be
hydrogen atoms not molecules into one
alpha particle two protons and two
neutrons bound together into a particle
that is identical to a helium nucleus
okay two positrons are released from
this process as well as two neutrinos
which changes two of the protons into
neutrons and energy
what in the world is energy what is this
word energy have no idea okay we'll find
out maybe 99% of the energy produced by
the sun takes place within 24% of the
sun's radius by 30% of the radius Fusion
has stopped almost entirely so Fusion
only happens within the 30% uh inner
percent of the uh radius okay closer to
24% where that's where 99% of the
process allegedly takes place according
to the establishment this is all done by
equations mathematically right that's
how they came up with all these numbers
the rest of the sun is heated by the
energy that is transferred from the core
through the successive layers so we're
transferring energy folks here you know
all these Concepts that they transfer
mathematical concept eventually reaching
the solar Photosphere and uh escaping
into space that sunlight or the kinetic
what energy of particles okay so that's
the official version
okay and here we have um a little
diagram of that I think it is here it is
yeah um and you can see how how this is
done two protons fused together
producing dyum hydrogen 2 and other
particles plus energy always add energy
there you know can't miss that whatever
that is right and that's the first step
the Second Step dyum hydrogen 2 and a
proton hydrogen one fuse okay so we have
two and one right right so now we have a
three ball um entity right producing
helium 3 and energy then two helium 3
nuclei fused together producing helium
four two protons hydrogen one and always
add energy hey we always have energy in
there thank God you know all that energy
and then number four the last uh step is
helium 3 fuses with helium uh for
producing brillium which decays and then
fuses with another proton hydrogen to
yield two helium 4 nuclei plus energy
okay so they have this is what they're
producing but then they produce this
thing called Energy which we have no
idea what it is okay but uh what is the
issue here uh which is the one I want to
clarify because the people may not be
aware of this fine detail and that's
what separates the establishment from us
so I do want to harp on that a little
bit if I can so you can see the
differences between what the
establishment proposing what we propose
here okay and here it is uh first I got
to go with this fellow his name is Larry
Krauss okay let me put him on here so uh
um you can see how he's going to
explain uh how this happens how how this
process goes okay and here he goes
listen
carefully okay he says protons don't
like to get close together uhhuh and he
says then uh they have to come together
with a huge amount of of energy or
velocity to get close enough to begin to
fuse okay so we have all of these balls
that come together but you can see
what's happening you know hydrogen atoms
slam together some of these collisions
are so powerful that atoms fuse
releasing energy so they're talking
about collisions in other words they're
saying that all these atoms or these
particles they travel inside the center
of the Sun so there's a lot of space
there and these guys are traveling at
Great speeds hitting one another they're
blending with the other merging with the
others or slamming into them and you
know merging somehow and when you have
several of these mergers uh you create a
helium atom and plus energy always right
don't forget about the energy and so
This Is How They explain it they say
look it's traveling at Great speeds you
can see that they're all traveling there
okay and this is going to be where we're
going to differ with these folks okay in
the traveling part okay so I'm going to
just keep that I just want to move now
to this energy thingy so that we all get
clear what energy is and for that what
better uh Source than a a Nobel Prize
winner here we have good old Dicky uh F
fan and he says it is important to
realize that in physics today we have no
knowledge of what energy
is now that's a scientific statement for
you we have no idea what we're talking
about okay great and you look it up
energy is defined as capacity right and
energy is also defined as the
quantitative quantitative property
transferred to an object how do you
transfer a quantitative property meaning
a number what do you do you throw it or
you slide it or how do you transfer that
so these people are using mathematical
Concepts as physical objects and they
talk about transferring like if you're
transferring a ball or a tree or a I
don't know a dog to someone else okay so
this is the problem that's why they have
no idea what energy is with good old
dicki there didn't understand is that um
energy is not a
what it's not a thing it's not a
something it's not an object energy is a
concept and you cannot use a concept to
explain a mechanism in physics period
we're done so these people have no idea
what they're talking about and when they
say they know and that they proveen and
they get a Nobel Prize you for sure you
can be absolutely sure they have no clue
whatsoever okay but that's the official
version uh probably the main opposition
to the official version comes from the
electric universe so let's go through
with through their little thingy okay
here we have the electric universe and I
think these people
are even worse than the establishment
here okay and this with the good old W
Thornhill who I think died in January
and I still have him as a friend in in
Facebook uh but go W he says the
following he says um that the sun is
like um you know electric bulb
essentially okay and they have this
plasma ball notion of what the sun is
and you can see that the current is
coming from outside it's coming from
other stars what he's saying is that all
stars in the universe are connected more
or less like a Christmas tree like
lights on a Christmas tree and in that
sense we have uh no no difference with
him because we agree that all atoms in
the universe are connected physically
connected where we have a problem is he
going to connect them with electricity
he says stars are connected what
electrically to a to the Galaxy there we
have a problem okay because electricity
is a concept it's not a physical object
electricity is something in motion
anything in motion is already a dynamic
concept okay uh uh the object is dog not
dog moving the object is boy not boy
running the object is Eagle not eagle
flying okay there's no such object
called eagle flying okay there's no such
object as fish swimming okay the object
is fish and the object is Eagle and
likewise you cannot say electrically
because electrically is not a thing so
you cannot connect things electrically
okay and uh this is uh essentially their
notion let me show you here give me a
second
here this is their this is their
Sun plasma ball that's that's the
electric Universe Sun most more or less
that's how they Envision it they say the
electricity comes from outside okay and
then it comes from every star in the
universe so it's electricity that binds
us or connects us to every star in the
universe and I got a big problem with
that okay I worked uh with because these
people know a lot about electricity or
they think they know because they can't
Define what electricity is but they know
absolutely nothing about vacuum okay
absolutely nothing they don't know what
vacuum is space out there is vacuum it's
not a perfect vacuum okay and I work
with uh with in in the semiconductor
industry for many years uh with minus 7
tour range so you go in there you take
atmosphere you know regular air that's
out in you know in the that you breathe
out here and you pump it down with a
mechanical pump rotary vein pump p pump
it down to the minus three level okay
then you it takes what takes over is
either diffusion pump or a cryo pump and
takes it down to the minus 7 Tor level
and that's the range you could call it
high vacuum that's what it's called uh
where you can operate and uh run the
machines introduce uh species such as
argon inert species that you can do
things with in the semiconductor
industry what happens at minus 7 you
have a very high vacuum for what we know
here on Earth space out there you know
empty space uh especially the solar wind
okay they think it's electric
electricity the solar wind is uh-12 to-3
T range there's hardly anything per
cubic
meter in that in that in that per in
other words per cubic meter there's
hardly any matter at all in that
block uh in other words the solar wind
is almost empty completely there's
nothing you can't run an electrical
current with a solar wind or uh you know
in uh on the moon which is also in Theus
11us 12 Range tour minus 11us 12 Tor
range so you have very high vacuum
there's nothing there com you know to
run a
current and people don't understand that
you can't run a current with zero with
in in the vacuum you need to put atoms
in there what what is it according to
the establishment right according to
what they teach you in high school and
college what is electricity it's the
flow of electrons what from atom to atom
you need atoms what we don't have in
space is atoms there's no atoms there to
take the little electron bead from atom
to atom that's if you follow the
establishment's version of course that's
not our version but if you follow the
establishment version which is what the
electric Universe uses the planetary
model the H the we'll do it with
hydrogen simp for Simplicity sake uh you
have a proton or a nucleus and you have
an electron bead what is electricity
according to the electric Universe a
little bead goes from atom to atom to
atom that's what it is the flow of atoms
you need the uh the flow of electrons
I'm sorry you need the atoms without the
atoms what is the electric the U the
electron bead flowing through or you
know across this is the problem these
people want to do electricity without
atoms and otherwise they're saying that
the whole universe space is covered with
atoms which is not true because then we
would have a true sandbox and then
you're talking about the real ether
there you sandbox okay that's not the
case Okay so uh this is according to the
electric Universe this is
electricity okay this is according to
the electric Universe okay says uh what
is the electric Universe the electric
Universe adds the essential role of
charge particles in motion what what are
you talking about charged particles in
motion I don't know what charged means I
mean uh does it carry a Visa or Master
Card uh I I'm not sure you know but they
say charge particles what particles are
they talking about they're talking about
electrons charged particles fill all of
space as electrically conductive plasma
this is absolute nonsense charged
particles do not fill space okay because
otherwise we'd have a Sandbox but these
people don't understand that says the
sun is plasma stars are plasma galaxies
are plasma absolutely not okay plasma is
is ionized gas that's what it is okay
and so they don't understand really what
what plasma is uh let alone electricity
the filaments of magnetized and
radiating matter between stars and
between galaxies or plasma so they think
the whole universe is filled with what
particles charged particles and that the
whole universe is vibrating with plasma
not only the stars but everything
between the Stars so we have you know I
guess these people never took a look at
space out there you know the black stuff
between the Earth and the moon uh that
black stuff they're saying is full of
plasma that's what they're saying okay
the isolated Islands we once imagined in
space do not exist a web of
electromagnetism connects planets no
electromagnetism is a concept you got to
tell me what physical object connects
planets Stars moons whatever galaxies
and they do not mention the the object
they say electromagnetism
electromagnetism is a concept you cannot
use a concept to bind anything to
connect anything the movement of charged
particles is an electric current okay so
they're saying that uh between the Stars
everything that's connected right uh
what they have is just current they have
the movement of electrons so how does
the movement of electrons bind the Earth
to something else how does it connect it
connect means that you know there's a
continuous
unbroken uh entity between two stars
that's not the case here they're saying
there's a flow there's a river flowing
from one um star to another okay and
they say these currents give rise to
pervasive magnetic fields and high
energy Etc again they use the same
language as the establishment energy
particles uh flow electricity and that's
why they cannot explain anything that's
why the electric Universe has no future
whatsoever because they're using the
same language as The Establishment and
that's where the problem is in the
language you know semantics uh word
salid that that's where the problem is
these people don't do word salid and
that's why they cannot explain anything
they have to do word salad you need to
establish the foundations of your theory
okay they don't do that okay so this is
a circuit according to them flow of
electron beads I guess right according
to the electric Universe right this is
what it is so you have two plates an
anode and a cathode you have all these
atoms between them because you need
atoms and what they say is the electron
beat is Flowing from one plate to the
other okay that's electricity for them
the flow of electron beads from atom to
atom that's the notion they have of
electricity and even if this were true
which it ain't okay uh even if this were
true uh you would need atoms and yeah
the only way they can uh explain their
theories by filling the universe space
you know every bit of space with atoms
okay because you have to have one at
them very close to the to another one
for the bead to be able to displace you
know the uh beat of the other atom or or
one leaves the hole and the other one
fills it or whatever however they want
to explain it so this is the notion
these people have of electricity and
with this so-called electricity which
they turn into a physical object they
turn the flowing water into a river a
continuous River and they say oh the
river connects you know the mountain to
the sea no no it doesn't connect it
because the river is made up of all
these little particles when you look at
it very closely so they're all separated
right it's not like you can pull on the
river and and pull the the ocean to the
mountain you can't do that okay because
what it's made out of all these discrete
particles pieces okay and that's the
case here if you're going to have the
for example if you're going to have uh
the Earth being drawn to the Sun by
gravity and they say that's it's not
gravity it's electricity great okay so
it's electricity how you pull with
electricity and at that point they say
well positive attracts
negative you start using the same
language of the mathematical
establishment that's the only way they
can to explain it they say look positive
attracts negative okay and yeah Mother
Nature doesn't understand what positive
and negative are she understands maybe
clockwise and counterclockwise but not
positive and negative she never went to
school and mother nature knows nothing
about math okay okay um so these are the
cosmic filaments this is the way the
electric Universe visualizes the
universe you know they say everything is
connected by these filaments and what
are those filaments where there those
are currents those are electrical
currents or electricity or however you
want to call it okay and you can see
that uh you cannot pull you cannot hold
the universe together with flowing beads
okay and you would have to have abs for
every bit of space which is also not the
case space is - 11 - 12 um uh to level
here in our neighborhood uh it's been
calculated
or hypothesize that um Interstellar
space is - 16 and then when you get out
to Intergalactic you get to the minus1
19 T level that's more or less the the
calculation this this the speculation
but to say that the entire universe is
fill with plasma absolutely not these
people have no idea what vacuum is they
should they should study vacuum not
electricity okay and this is this is
where they fail okay so here we have um
we'll con seed their
electricity let's go with this okay we
have two stars here they look like our
sun right and they say electricity is
Flowing you can see the electricity all
these electron beads going in One
Direction and the other you know and so
the question here is how do you bind
these and uh did the electron beats flow
without atoms uh is this how this works
How the Universe works and I'm to show
you here two stars if there are stars in
every direction radial direction from a
from our Star from our sun uh you know
the whole universe is filled with ANS
space is not empty space is filled it's
all the way around space is a Sandbox
according to these people and so you
know and for some reason it's activated
it's all plasma and and so yeah we have
a lot of problem with uh what the electr
universe is proposing which I think is
worse than what the establishment is
proposing okay the only part that they
got right is that uh stars are connected
the question is what connects them
that's what you have to identify that
was the key issue how are they connected
they cannot be connected by
electromagnetism they cannot be
connected by electricity by the flow of
beads there's no atoms out there in
space so what could
you know the Stars what connects the
planets to our sun okay and that's what
they've never identified on the other
hand the um establishment I think they
got it right as far as Fusion is
concerned that's how I think it works
inside the Sun the problem I've got with
what they propose is that inside the sun
because remember it's all gravitational
according to them and according to me we
all agree on this it's gravitational the
sun is compressing itself day after day
after day after day and after no
millions of years you now becomes more
or less a cinder at some point but what
happens when you're
compressing atom against atam against
atam inside the Sun you're talking about
you know um you're talking about gases
assuming let's assume for a second that
the sun is all hydrogen okay it's going
to turn some of that hydrogen into
helium we're talking about brand new St
here okay so it's compressing it's it's
compressing gravitational Le if you go
inside the Sun if you could go to the
center of the sun b men you think you
would have a lot of space to move around
and fly and Collide against other
atoms I think not I think you would be
squashed in there you know Adam against
Adam you have all this from every side
remember this is a sphere for those who
are not flat earthers and it's
compressing from every side right
compressing compressing compressing
compressing and it squashes one atom
against another and so yeah this this is
where we have a problem with
them um and so yeah this this is what
the um what is it the uh electric
Universe propos it says you know they
have this flow of rocks and how do you
attract with that how do you connect
something with that and so here we have
my good old friend cassimir and he's
throwing uh he's putting on the Dunkey
by throwing rocks at him and here's our
cowboy and he does something similar he
does it with waves he has throw these
waves one way and for some reason you
know the donkey is attracted towards you
so they have all these mechanisms that
they want to do with particles and it
don't work it simply don't work you know
so these people are rby out of their
need when they try to use their brains
that's where the problem is okay so here
we have U our version okay what happens
inside the Sun well there's a lot of
compression going on there's still some
vibration in there the atoms they tend
to vibrate and move around but they have
very very little room maybe maybe they
don't move much at all but they're being
compressed from every side and now we
can see why you know four hydrogen atoms
are compressed into a helium atom okay
we can see that okay and so here I try
to illustrate it this what we would see
inside the center of the sun maybe some
slight vibration there uh I had to put
that in there just to give you an idea
that there could be some movement in
there even though they're being
compressed against each other and what
happens as they're compressed by gravity
you have this situation where you know
they compressed from the outside um and
squashed against each other okay so I
think there's very little movement in
the center of the Sun what you really
have is compression of atom against atom
and that's where you have hydrogen being
turned into helium and later on into
heavier elements okay so that's in
general terms uh what we propose okay so
the difference with The Establishment we
agree with Fusion there is a fusion
going on there due to gravity but
there's no movement it's not that one
collides a great speeds against another
which is what they do in the
accelerators that's where they got the
idea they say oh these U atoms these
electrons or these protons whatever they
want to use in there uh they're running
at Great speeds and colliding at at
Great speeds like two cars crashing
against each other we say that's not
what happens what happens is you have
something from the outside squashing to
two cars together and turning them into
one more or less you know
metal scrap metal okay so that's what we
think were happening so here you have uh
just a vision of that okay you have here
our two atoms which are uh membranes
that encapsulate a proton star Remember
the ropes end at the electron shell the
red one in this case we colorcoded it so
that you can distinguish it the red one
turns into to the um uh electron shell
it weaves a surface uh which is the
surface of the atom in this case the
hydrogen atom and the other one
continues straight towards the center
and comes out the other end or somewhere
in the other end and forms these proton
Stars so we have an electron membrane
not an electron bead rolling around a
nucleus but an electron membrane that
encapsulates the proton star this is our
atom and when they're squashed together
you can see what happens the uh uh
electron membranes merge okay they blend
into each other okay here we have four
of them so this is more or less what we
propose uh happens when four hydrogen
atoms uh turn into a helium atom and
obviously there are other processes this
is very a very simplified version of
what we propose but you can see what
we're proposing uh essentially we're
squashing four hydrogen atoms to make
one Helen atom and what comes out of
there is what we call what they call
energy and we have to figure out what
this energy thingy is is there such a
thing called Energy uh and well first
let me show you the the helian atom when
you have those four squashed together
you get something that looks more or
less like this a ball okay it's the S1
and S2 level and um essentially it's a
sphere that's what you get and the
question is why do they because this is
from The Establishment this is from
chemistry and you can see that they show
this these two little electron beads why
do they put a sphere what is that sphere
and that sphere is supposedly an energy
level or an orbital that's what they
call it but they don't think of it as a
physical membrane they think of it as a
region where you can find or within
which you can find the electron bead
that's why they put those beads in there
and we're saying there are no beads what
you have is is a membrane that's all you
have okay for the helium atom as well as
for the hydrogen atom okay so
um
um what is this energy stuff because if
you merge these you can see that a
helium atom doesn't weigh as much
doesn't have as much mass as four
hydrogen atoms so what happened to the
rest of it where did all the mass go
they said they turn into energy you know
e comes mc^ s Okay so turn into energy
what is this energy okay well that's the
Heat and the light that comes out of the
sun where does it go or How does it go
how does it get out of there okay it
gets out through the same mechanism that
we have for Gravity okay what is gravity
so let's look at gravity here it is
gravity gravity means that or why the
Earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system every atom of the earth is bound
physically bound to every atom of the
sun they're bound to it through the
ropes that we just showed a minute ago
and what you have is torsions along each
one of those ropes is what we call light
okay and uh so we have light and gravity
in a single mechanism known as the grand
unified theory okay where we have the
two mechanisms in one and yeah what the
sun does is once it squashes the four
hydrogen atoms into a helium atom it
releases along the ropes connecting
every one of those atoms to whatever is
out there in the universe it releases
the so-called energy which is uh the
torsions propagating along each one of
the ropes that connects any two atoms in
the
universe okay so that is our model okay
you can see it's a little different than
what the establishment proposes we're
saying there's a single thread in the
entire universe This Thread is what um
binds around itself itself twins around
itself creates all the atoms in the
universe and each atom is bound to any
other atom through the same pair of
threads okay that are twined around each
other and light consists of torsions
along that the that rope and at the same
time that rope serves as the mechanism
for Gravity now we have now we have um
not action at a distance it's just that
we can't see or touch the mediators so
if we have uh for
example where is it uh here we have a
little spoon okay and we say why does it
fall to the floor right we let go of it
and it comes down okay it falls always
never falls to the ceiling I don't know
why but it always falls downward why
because it's
attracted in other words it's not
attracted what happens is as as the uh
spoon gets closer and closer to the
Earth the um ropes fan out because the
atoms are getting closer that's why it's
a distance phenomena square of the
distance phenomena but as the spoon gets
closer as the atoms get closer to the
atoms of the Earth the ropes that bind
each one of those atoms to every atom on
Earth they fan out fan out fan out more
and that's where you have this
acceleration of gravity so in a single
mechanism uh the Rope you have light and
you have gravity uh that's something
that uh mathematicians will never
discover even if they come to this
channel
okay let's go with some of the questions
people asked uh couple of them here that
I picked out F says even your theory
uses mathematics um
no theory is an
explanation math an equation any
equation is a description okay so you
got to learn the basics guy you know I
mean Jesus they come up with these
issues they don't realize they they
failed kindergarten physics right there
okay so no mathematics is not an
explanation therefore it's not part of
any Theory we don't use mathematics in
science at all mathematics is a
language nothing but a language is
Chinese the language of physics is uh
maybe Russian the language of physics if
math is just a language why do you say
that math is the language of physics the
language of physics is illustration you
need to put objects on the screen and
show us what the mechanis ism is for
Gravity for light for uh magnetism
electricity whatever you got
to you got to put things you know
objects on the screen then we can
understand your theory how it works okay
if you do math you haven't understood
squat you haven't understood the
mechanism that's only a description
saying uh that the pen Falls an
acceleration of 9.8 m/s squared you
haven't explained anything you haven't
explained why what caused that
acceleration with the ropes you can so
now you have an explanation for why the
acceleration of gravity is what it is
9.8 m/s Square here on Earth okay what
is it one six of it on the Moon by the
way okay so here we have um another fell
and he says what Michaelson Mory
experiment never demonstrated ether does
not exist S effect is his best
proof Okay so we have to correct this
individual we have to say ether what is
it that we Define The Ether okay because
it's a concept it's not an object if it
were an object I would point to it but
since it's a concept we Define it many
particles many discrete particles that's
what ether is you don't like my
definition you put your definition okay
that's how simple it is defend your
definition okay but then if you define
it it's not an object because objects we
point to Concepts we Define so you
better not Define if you're going to use
it as an object as a thing if you're
going to say oh The Ether vibrates or
The Ether goes this way or that now you
can't say that because the ether is a
concept if you want it as an object you
have to point to it meaning you have to
draw it you have to point to a picture
of it make a mockup of it uh take a
snapshot whatever put it on the internet
show us the ether that you have in your
head I don't care what the ether really
is I want the one that's in your head
that's the one I want you to put out
there if you can't do that don't talk
about The Ether you can't use the word
ether because all you said is X the X
does this well what is X oh I don't know
but the X does it no you got to define
the words if it's a concept you got to
point to them if it's an object very
simple ether is not a thing ether is a
concept okay and uh what does exist mean
exist means that you need a thing it's
got to be an object something right plus
location so uh exist adds to the word
object
location and and so since ether is a
concept you cannot say that ether does
exist okay you can't talk about the
existence of a concept Concepts cannot
be said to exist and just in case in
science we do not prove anything proof
is religion proof has to do with
convincing you proof has to do with uh
persuading the jury okay recruiting
that's all religion not science so yeah
don't don't talk about best proof or
whatever okay and last issue here F says
your counterargument against wheeler
isn't making sense to me he's talking
about uh our baldheaded um Buddha there
guy who talks about uh what the counter
space isn't making sense to me okay this
is H2O this is H2O moving like this H2O
moving like this is called water this is
H2O moving like this is called ice and
each like this is called steam okay each
observable phenomenon is a different
modality of H2O what's wrong with that
as a
proposition uhuh well uh he continued
says this is The Ether this is The Ether
moving like this ether moving like this
is called D electricity okay uh ether
moving like that it's called magnetism
and ether moving like that other thing
it also moves like this uh it's called
what dielectricity magnetism or whatever
okay each observable phenomenon is a
different modality of ether what's wrong
with that proposition well the
difference is that I can freeze water
you know a picture I can take a snapshot
of water and there you have one okay A
little drawing and I can point to that
say that's water okay you got it because
I can point to it what are we going to
point to with ether is ether the same
thing as water or like water in the
sense is it a is it a thing can I point
to The Ether if so put a picture there
next time and then we'll point to The
Ether and we can use all the modality
that you want but first we need a
snapshot a still image of The Ether
until you can do that you cannot talk
about The Ether if you think it's a
concept Define it but then don't use it
as a physical object you cannot say The
Ether does this you can't use it as a
noun as a subject of a sentence you
can't say The Ether does this you can't
put an article in front of it the or a
or n no you have to point and say ether
like you would point to a tree or a dog
or a house and say house then it's okay
because now we can identify what you
mean what you have in your head
regarding the ether but don't talk about
The Ether until you do that okay you
can't start talking and say The Ether
does this no no point to it first then
we'll worry about what it does point to
it if it's a concept Define it very
simple we'll see you next week Sunday
byebye